um guys remember how
after the 2020 election donald trump
never really admitted that he lost
and he never really conceded but he
eventually started saying
things like the next administration and
we were kind of like that's
kind of a concession and he said to sean
hannity last week
we didn't win and we said oh
it's kind of trump admitting that he
didn't win trump has now resurfaced
in a completely laughable embarrassing
and pathetic excuse for an interview on
a program called
just the news on a channel i guess
called
real america's voice i i don't know what
any of this stuff is
to tell the interviewer david brody that
trump never admitted defeat
and that trump still has not conceded
the 2020 election
it has to be seen to be believed
and that is exactly what we are going to
do here is the first clip listen to this
insanity
i want to start with something you told
sean hannity last week the headlines
were about how
you admitted defeat in the 2020 election
when you said we didn't
win is that an accurate headline did you
admit defeat i just want to understand
that
no i never admitted defeat by the way
how bad does he sound
no i never admitted defeat of a
lot of things happening right now i
think that that was an election that was
i don't think all you have to do is read
the newspapers and
see what's coming out now no i never
the word is concede i have not conceived
so there is trump saying
i have not conceded and i have not
admitted defeat now
remember conceding defeat is not legally
relevant and it's not legally binding
in any way this is how trump strings
along his ignorant followers oh wow
did you that was a signal trump didn't
technically
admit defeat something's coming he
hasn't conceded
conceding is legally irrelevant it's
electorally irrelevant it's a formality
that normal adult politicians
engage in when they've lost but it is
legally meaningless and trump is also
straight up lying
he said to hannity we didn't win he
wildly said we'll see what happens with
that
alluding to this return to office in
august but this is just last week
remember this guys
you ever considered it and are you
considering it
well i am and frankly if you think of it
that's what i've been doing and talking
about
for a long time and i guess that's why
we got him by surprise in 16
and in 20 we did much better than we did
in 16 and
[Music]
shockingly we were supposed to win
easily at 64 million votes and we got 75
million votes and
we didn't win but we didn't win the
whole thing
but we'll see what happens on that trump
said it
now he denies saying it he lies all the
time
uh period and um he now plays
coy with the term concession and it's
all just
a joke this entire interview was bonkers
uh trump continues to blame mike pence
for accepting the 2020 election results
as if he had a choice right he's still
disappointed in
pence i don't want to listen to the new
york times they always like to write
about the relationship between you and
mike pence
can you explain that to us right now
there's a portion of the mag a crowd you
know the deal they're never going to
forgive
the vice president for not kicking uh
those certain disputed election results
back to uh state legislatures what's
your what's your take on mike pence and
and and how what's the relationship like
well i've uh always liked mike and i'm
very disappointed that he didn't send it
back to the legislatures when you have
more
votes than you have voters in some cases
now that's not true
you didn't have more votes than voters
and again disappointed
pence couldn't do anything pence
couldn't do anything and
trump's own followers don't know that
they now heckle pence as traitor
and uh unpatriotic and whatever else
when you have the kind of things that
are
that were known in many cases they were
known then but
they're certainly getting better and
better known now
i was disappointed that he didn't send
it back i felt he had the right to send
it back
and uh he should have sent it back he is
completely wrong
pence had no ability to do anything he
could have tried some stuff that would
have been historically humiliating
he really couldn't do anything but it
doesn't matter in the world of trump
that's my opinion and i think if he did
i think those legislate
look at pennsylvania now look at look at
georgia and look at
arizona and look at others they're all
now looking at what happened during that
election
nothing will come of it trump continues
to string his followers along
nothing will come of these fake audits i
think you would have found that
uh you might very well have a different
president right now
you would not you would not what you
would have would be
an even more humiliated former
vice president and former president
pence and trump that's what you would
have but
pence couldn't do anything about it
trump also asked about 2024. his
comments they're
sort of interesting on 2024 by the way
here's my take and i'm curious to get
your take would it be accurate to say
that if a super majority of the
candidates that you're supporting right
now
if they win in in the midterms and
republicans take back the house and the
senate
uh that would make it more likely that
you would run at that point is that true
what do you think no i don't think so
but i think that's what is going to
happen
now this is super interesting trump is
asked are you more likely to run if the
people you support in 22
do well and trump says no it's the wrong
question and the right question
shouldn't even be asked of trump because
he'll just lie the right question is
are you more likely to win if the people
you support in 22 do well and that's
ultimately what this
hinges on and hangs on and that's what
we've been talking about
trump needs to successfully have his
coalition uh the cow thorns and the
boberts and the marjory taylor greens
they need to do well in 2022
to bolster trump for 24. i think trump
may well run
regardless of whether he does well in 22
but his
chances will be greatly diminished if
the people he supports don't win
in the midterm election let's continue
my endorsements have meant a lot
we're almost undefeated very close to
undefeated
understand that with trump at the helm
of the republican
ship they lost the house in 2018
they lost the senate in 2020 and they
lost the white house in 2020. trump
undefeated that's
wrong in a literal sense but the spirit
of what he's saying he's been in a sense
a disaster for the republican party
they've lost everything
hundreds and hundreds of endorsements uh
people win
the republican party chair in north
carolina
and in georgia and a lot of these are
meaningless endorsements where there's
like really not anybody running or
there's one real candidate and it's an
often an incumbent
and to say that trump's endorsement has
any value there
that's really a stretch places we just
had congressional candidates but i mean
hundreds
of endorsements and our record is i
think unmatched anywhere
at any time so i'm looking to
gain the majority first and i think it
would be
i think it's very important that we do
that i don't know that would have any
impact on my decision however
that may be true it may not impact
trump's decision
but it definitely impacts his viability
just a little bit more of this
have that impact on your decision what's
going through your mind on that a lot of
people want to know
well i think i'm just looking at uh
what's going on i'm very unhappy with
what's going on i look at the border
where people are coming in by the
millions it's going to be by the minions
very soon
so notice that how he slips that in
they're coming in by the millions he
knows that that's not really true
so he says soon it's going to be my by
the millions and of course it's not
it already is uh oh and i look at
other things how our country is really
it's america last i was america first
i look at it and i see what's happening
and i'm not happy about it so just
meaningless drivel as i've told you
before the standing and reputation of
the united states around the world
was greatly diminished under donald
trump uh it's been greatly bolstered
early in joe biden's
presidency doesn't mean biden's perfect
doesn't mean biden is even great on
policy it's just the reputation of the
united states around the world so
just about every aspect of this
completely backwards during the
interview but the key point there trump
again playing coy i didn't concede i
didn't concede
when the reality is the concession is
unnecessary and it's just another way to
continue
stringing along his low information
voters into saying well maybe he will
come back because technically he didn't
concede much more of this stuff is to be
expected
as we get closer and closer to the 2022
midterms and trump needs to put some
wins up on the board
one of our sponsors is rise the
science-based app that makes it easy to
improve your sleep and your daily energy
rise helps you figure out what are your
sleep needs helps you achieve your best
possible sleep
through two core principles of sleep
science the idea of sleep debt meaning
how much sleep you owe your body
and circadian rhythms dictating your
energy levels each morning
the rise app tells you how long you'll
be groggy
what your energy peaks will be during
the day when you should start winding
down for bed
for optimal sleep i've been using the
app on my phone every day for a while
now
and i started noticing improved sleep
and energy within just a few nights
and it's giving me a really good
understanding of the relationship
between
my sleep and when i'm sleeping and my
daytime energy
my audience can try rise for free for a
whole week
by going to rise science.com
pacman the link is underneath this video